On March 23, all of a sudden, the Russian president Vladimir Putin gave
orders to the Russian Central Bank and the Gazprom national
corporation to take on a new mechanism to levy Russian natural gas payments sold for "Unfriendly" countries
in ruble (the Russian national currency). Putin demanded, in his speech to the government
to exhaust the issue in just one week, which means that, by the 30th of March
all the ‘Unfriendly’ countries have to start paying in Russian ruble
Which countries are unfriendly? Countries that imposed
sanctions on Russia after Ukraine invasion on 24 February
the number of those countries goes up to 48 countries, Chief among which are the United States
European Union states, Britain, Japan, Canada, Norway
Singapore, South Korea, Switzerland and Ukraine itself
The decision is the first by Russia considering the use of natural
gas supplies as a weapon in the ongoing conflict between it and the West regarding the war in Ukraine
It came at a time wherein the Russian economy is facing the most serious crisis in years (since the dissolution of the Soviet Union)
it also deepens the confrontation with Western world and could exacerbate the worst energy crisis in Europe, since the 1970s
due to its heavy dependence on Russian gas for heating and power generation
That is why the prices of natural gas in Europe rose by 30% after this decision
Putin's clear message was: You want our gas, You need our currency
On this subject, we ask a few questions: What is the rejoinder of countries that are not friendly
to Russia regarding a decision like this? Do they really pay in rubles?
Were the contracts between Russia and these countries originally paid in rubles?
Why does Russia want them to pay in rubles for gas?
Will this affect the highly dominated US dollar all over the world?
What would be the other possible options if those countries refrained from payment in Ruble?
All these questions and more are going to be answered in today's episode
I am Ashraf Ibrahim and this is the Economic Informant
This episode is sponsored by 'Thiqa website'
which is a platform specialized in evaluating licensed and trusted trading and investment companies.
Thiqa provides educational articles on trading and investing in the money and stock markets and the secrets of investing in stocks.
You will find links in the video description and in Facebook comments, join us their and take a tour and learn how to invest in companies costume like Amazon and more..
Russia is the richest country in the world with gas
it has a total of 47 trillion cubic meters of natural gas reserves
It is also the largest exporter of natural gas all over the world
About 196 billion cubic meters are shipped annually from
Russia to different countries all over the world, so to speak
Our main concerns in today's episode are; Russia's exports of
natural gas to Europe, which is Russia's largest gas importer over the past decades
Gazprom, a national corporation owned by the Russian government
is in control of everything related to natural gas in Russia
including natural gas supplies to other countries
It supplies Europeans with 40% of their needs of natural gas
Most of those 40% pass through pipelines as follows
The first network of pipelines are transport corridors across Ukraine
It includes the Brotherhood pipeline, which is the oldest in the region
It was constructed in 1967 from Russia through Ukraine to end in Slovakia
In 1984, the Urengoy - Pomary - Uzhgorod line was adopted
which is in fact Not just one line, but a stream of gas lines
connected together and extending from the Urengoy gas field in
Siberia to the city of Uzhhorod in the far west of Ukraine
and from there to Slovakia. After 4 years of that one
the ‘Progress line’ was constructed and it extended from the
Yamburg gas field in northern Russia; following the same route of the Urengoy–Pomary–Uzhgorod pipeline to Slovakia
As you can see, all these lines go far to Slovakia
From Slovakia, there are two branches: one goes to the Czech Republic
and from there it reaches the municipality of Weidhaus in
Bavaria on the Czech-German border
The other one goes from Slovakia to Austria
and from Austria to Italy and Slovenia
All these countries depend on Russian gas.
There is a fourth gas pipeline that passes through Ukraine
the So yuz gas pipeline, which was built in 1980 and extends
from Orenburg in southwestern Russia all through Ukrainian
lands passing by Hungary
to deliver gas to Slovakia and Romania as well
Still in Ukraine as well, there is a transit gas pipeline built in 1986
and it passes through the Ukrainian and Romanian
lands delivering gas to Bulgaria
Turkey, Greece and North Macedonia
This is the group of gas pipelines that pass through Ukraine and
transport 41.6 billion cubic meters of gas to Europe in 2021
The second main pipeline that connects Russia to Europe is
Nord Stream 1 which runs under the Baltic Sea from Portovaya
Bay near the city of Vyborg in western Russia
to the German coast near Greifswald
with a length of 1,224 km
This giant pipeline was built in 2011
and it delivers almost 55 billion cubic meters of gas
from which Germany, the United Kingdom, the Netherlands
France, Denmark and other European countries benefit
The third main pipeline that delivers Russian gas to Europe is Yamal-Europe
It is a long pipeline that collects gas from natural gas fields
in the Yamal Peninsula and Western Siberia and goes through
Belarusian lands, then Polish lands to Germany
with a length of 4107 km
It was constructed in 1996
with a full capacity of 33 billion cubic meters of natural gas
These were the pipelines that transported Russian natural gas
to European countries and which transported most of the
quantities that Russia exported to Europe as a whole
Over the past year, 2021, Russia exported 155 billion cubic
meters of gas to Europe through this pipeline network
Nevertheless, these countries whose economic life depends strategically on the Russian natural gas that flows in these pipelines
are suddenly obliged to pay in rubles, otherwise, the natural gas pumps may be turned off
Well, the question that pops up here is: How much do Russian gas exports cost in the first place? What currency were the former financial transactions in?
Attention please!
According to the Central Bank of Russia
Russia's total exports in 2021 went up to $489.8 billion
Gas and LNG pipelines made $61.8 billion
So to speak, about 12.6% of the total exports come from gas
Furthermore, the countries hostile to Russia,
which the latter demands to pay in rubles
account for almost 70% of Russian gas exports
What was the currency in which these countries used to pay in?
According to Gazprom, natural gas sales to Europe
and other countries were settled as follows
58% of sales were in euros, 39% were in dollars
and about 3% were in sterling
Naturally, the euro is the most paid currency in gas sales
because Europe is Russia's largest client
This takes us to the situation of these countries regarding the Russian decision to pay in rubles
The European community in particular, once they knew, told Putin that it is impossible to pay in rule and he must stop joking!
European Commission President Ursula von der Leyen
said that this step is just an attempt to circumvent EU sanctions against Russia
She said: “We will not allow our sanctions to be circumvented. The time when energy could be used to blackmail us is over.”
The German Economy Minister said that Putin's demand for payment in rubles is “a unilateral and clear breach of existing contracts”
The Minister of Finance advised German energy suppliers not to pay for Russian gas in rubles
and said: “We cannot accept Putin’s terms, but stick to the contracts as they were concluded.”
The CEO of PGNiG, the largest Polish energy company, which contracted with Gazprom
said simply that the company will not pay in rubles, adding that the other partner in the contract - Gazprom - can not change the method of payment in such a way
The same is Italy which announced that payment will be in euros as used to
The United States has no part in this matter of course as it imposed an immediate ban on Russian oil and gas imports
The United Kingdom said it will gradually ban gas imports by the end of the year 2022
Apart from Europe and the United States, which are at the center of the confrontation with Russia
It is noticed that the reaction of Asian customers was pretty softer
Japan, which is the largest importer of Russian liquefied natural gas in Asia
said that it is studying the implications regarding payment in rubles
South Korea, which is the third largest importer of liquefied natural gas in Asia
said that it would do anything to continue importing Russian gas
which clearly means that they have no problem paying in rubles
So, what is expected to happen if European countries refuse to pay in rubles?
Most likely, the catastrophe that the whole world has been afraid of
since the beginning of the Russian war on Ukraine will happen
There will be no more Russian gas for Europe
What happened hours before the filming of this episode on Monday, March 28
says that the situation is just heading this way
As the presidency of the Group of Seven recently took place
the ministers of the industrialized countries rejected Russia's demands to pay in rubles
At the same time, Russia said that it would not provide Europe
with gas for free because it offered mechanisms for paying in
rubles and it is them who refused
Kremlin spokesman Dmitry Peskov said sarcastically that in our
current situation we cannot participate in charitable works
meaning that they can not provide gas to European customers for free
He said that Russia will take decisions in due course if European
states refuse to pay in the Russian currency
Putin’s decision put the Europeans in a real dilemma, so to speak
If they refuse to pay in rubles, insisting that Russia is committing a unilateral violation of contracts
the gas pumping will be turned off
If they do pay in rubles, they will be  supporting the Russian ruble, thus easing the sanctions imposed on Russia
This last point highlights a logical question: why does Russia want gas payments to be in ruble?
Isn't it supposed that the country needs hard currency like the euro and dollar?
It is not always the case, everything has a time and place
Payment in rubles, if it happens, will lead to an increase in demand for
it by gas customers in the list of unfriendly countries previously clarified
This will consequently lead to an increase in its value against other major currencies
Repercussions actually took place since the decision was made
The ruble went from depreciating to stabilizing
At the time of writing this episode, the exchange value is $1 for 99 ruble
Although it is 17% weaker than its normal levels before the Russian invasion of Ukraine
it is stronger than it was on March 7 when it reached its lowest level which was 151 rubles per dollar
Moreover, it is expected that its value will rise up even more if the importing countries agree to pay in ruble
Secondly, this will force customers, especially Europeans, to buy rubles
from Russian banks that are subject to sanctions, and this means that sanctions will be eased
Third, the sanctions created an unprecedented economic isolation for Russia
which is not even able to use the surplus dollars or euros
It is merely like imprisoning someone with one million dollars in a room
They would starve to death though being surrounded by money
Russia has a surplus in the current account, which includes the trade surplus
meaning that the value of its exports is more than the value of its imports
In 2021, it achieved a surplus of 120.3 billion dollars
Fourthly, despite the aforementioned points, the dollar and the euro will settle in Russia in the end
as the Western companies will buy the ruble and sell the dollar and the euro to Russian banks
So, a demand for the ruble, that did not exist before, is being created
The fifth and most important thing is that the pricing and settlement of global commodities such as oil and gas
in major currencies, specifically the dollar and the euro, will strengthen their position and prove their dominance over international trade
That is why 80% of global reserves are in dollars and euros
Surely Russia will bend all backwards to shake this hegemony
This drives us to a significant question: Will Russia's pay in ruble decision
affect the dollar's dominance over the global economy?
This step can be considered an extension of Russia’s attempt to remove the dollar from its economy;
an attempt it started with China since Western countries imposed sanctions on Russia
after its annexation of the Crimea peninsula in 2014
For example, Russia replaced the dollar with the euro or local currencies in trade between Russia, China and India,
reducing the Russian Central Bank’s holdings of US dollar reserves,
and excluding dollar assets from the sovereign wealth fund.
All these were attempts to influence the dollar’s hegemony in the world,
and the move to pay in rubles is just a new step in the way.
However, Considering what things have come to, it is crystal clear that Putin’s decision had a small effect
On the contrary, the US dollar index USDX, which measures the value of the dollar against the most important six other major currencies
namely the euro, the Japanese yen, the British pound
the Canadian dollar, the Swedish krona and the Swiss franc,
shows a rise in the value of the dollar against all these other major currencies
from the beginning of 2022 until the time of writing this episode by 3%.
In short, the pay in ruble decision will have a very limited impact on the dominance of the dollar
In short, Russia is adamant in the pay in ruble decision and will not back down one iota.
The countries that it describes as hostile / unfriendly must acquiesce in this.
On the other hand, European countries will be most affected by this issue, as they are adamant not to pay in ruble.
So, what is going to happen is subjected to several scenarios, we will not address them all,
but the most important three of them, and they are as follows:
The first scenario is that the deadline, that still has two days from the time of filming this episode,
ends and each party adheres to its position, so, Russia starts cutting off the gas pipelines to Europe
for the first time since the seventies when the Soviet Union began building these gas pipelines.
Here the Europeans will be subjected to a drastic crisis that their continent has not witnessed in decades,
a crisis as a result of which factories will stop running, houses electricity will be cut off,
natural gas prices will rise terribly, and a major state of paralysis and economic confusion will occur
The second scenario is that some European countries agree to pay in rubles, as the deadline Putin has put is approaching,
while others refuse, risking Russia might have to cut off gas to their countries.
At that time, these countries will try to compensate for the shortage of Russian gas from other sources
such as liquefied natural gas from the United States and Qatar
However, this will raise Natural gas prices all across Europe too, but not as high as expected at the previous scenario
The third scenario is that all European countries refuse to pay in rubles
and here instead of cutting off energy supplies to all of Europe;
Russia will be satisfied with operating one or two main pipelines,
consequently a major energy crisis will break out all over the continent pushing gas prices to rise highly,
this consequently will put pressure on European governments
to the extent that they would settle an agreement anyway.
Here, Russia does not take the option of Samson bringing down the columns and collapsing the temple over everyone's,
in contrast it leaves an empty room to accord on a common ground.
This is a scenario that we can consider as a pinch from Russia in order to force European countries
to agree upon terms that will lead to the Russians real gains.
In your opinion, which of all these scenarios is the most likely to happen?
Is it possible to see a pure fourth scenario in the coming days? I will follow up all your answers in the comments.
In the end, like and share and subscribe to the channel if you like the episode,
tell your friends about the channel, they may like it too, Goodbye.